il l'avait choisie pour couler des jours
heureux mais la résidence de standing
situé en centre ville de blois a
subitement fermé ses portes sans
explication résultats du jour au
lendemain aux personnes âgées ont dû
trouver un nouveau logement
un mois après certains sont encore sur
place épaulés par d'anciens salariés qui
refusent de les abandonner paul boyer
tous des sacs sans la voyez avec toutes
mes affaires
un petit peu de vaisselle aimé mes
affaires mais abbey cette résidente de
la maison pour seniors l'amiral de
coligny à blois va bientôt devoir partir
le 11 mai dernier
la résidence est placé sur liquidation
judiciaire par le tribunal de commerce
de lyon une malheureuse surprise pour
les onze personnes âgées qui habitent le
lieu on vous dit vous avez plus de dix
jours à vivre ici qu'on vous laisse rien
qu'on vous dit rien quoi au juste
ben voilà faut payer vos bagages du
parti quoi ça c'est très dur
depuis une semaine c'est le branle bas
de combat pour trouver des solutions
d'urgence pour chaque résident la
brutalité de la décision a pris tout le
monde de court
pour marc toro résidents de 94 ans
arrivé ici en 2017 c'est la douche
froide
je n'ai jamais été au courant une vie
une fashion verbale ni par écrit
aucun document je les chu simplement car
le personnel
stefan houfani mondiaux vendredi
on élit changé vous n'avez plus rien la
société vitei gestionnaire du site a
licencié les quatre salariés dont la
directrice par courrier recommandé afin
de ne pas laisser les personnes âgées
mourir de faim deux auxiliaires de vie
ont fait le choix de rester à dire on
reste là on va se la même sur l'épopée
on s'en fout c'est pas de problème ça
c'est le problème c'est que on jette pas
des anciens à la rue comme ça il y en a
qu'on peut de famille c'est également
par dévouement que fanny capes a décidé
de continuer le temps de trouver une
solution pour chaque résident on était
comme une petite famille et il
s'entendait tous bien aidé à les voir se
dire aurevoir entre
ça fait très mal au coeur mandaté par le
tribunal de commerce le cabinet d'études
situé à lyon a refusé de nous répondre
pour l'heure six résidents ont déjà été
relogées notamment à l'ehpad des
écureuils de blois des solutions sont en
cours pour les autres sans aucune
garantie pour le moment